do either of you have any good shark
stories that happened either before the
filming during or after thanks shark
stories I don't have any sharks I just
have a tremendous respect for sharks you
know I think that they're there they're
prehistoric animals they're beautiful
they have a tremendous importance to the
the Otzi you know the life of this
either the you know with the word I want
but in some of the ecosystem of the
ocean and I know that that they're
quickly becoming extinct because we're
killing about a hundred million of them
a year for their fins for soup and and
for sport you know and it's so when we
think of the predator of the sea the
really the biggest predator of the sea
is man and with interesting about this
film is that the sharks aren't being
hunted it's the people who are being
hunted and I feel like there's a kind of
poetic justice the idea that the you
know the sea the Sharks the environment
will bite back if we don't treat it with
you know the proper respect so yeah
there's a scene in the film where the
two sisters are 47 meters down there in
a precarious situation and one confesses
that the other that they were
competitive I'm wondering for the two of
you in real life has anyone ever
confessed to you that they were
competitive in regards to an acting
career and how you took that because it
could be a compliment it could make you
competitive that's a good really good
quality good question
I know that the most successful actors
that I've worked with I won't have to
name any names that they can be very
friendly and cooperative and then once
they put the clapper and say action they
would step on your throat to to beat you
in a scene that that and it was it was
so funny to me because the education
that I received when I was studying to
be an actor was that you you play with
one another that your scene partners
that if I'm a good tennis player and the
person that I'm playing again is not
very good what I have to do is try to
improve their game because I'm not going
to be able to have a good game and show
you how good a player I am if the other
player can't hit the ball back to me so
if I'm just smashing the ball and making
the person run all over the place
the
that it's just it's not going to work
that you want to try to make the scene
as best as possible I'll name a name you
know when we got when we got the set
everyone's nervous and excited and you
know you don't know what to expect and
literally the moment I met Matthew he
just put us and you don't know what to
expect you put us all at ease and we
just had we and we talked about this
like that he he had this way of making
us feel like we were being looked out
for you know and being cared for and
that you know when the camera was on us
he was going to be there for us making
sure that we got our we got our best
performances out but then also that when
we're going out to the ocean we're doing
you scuba diving things and so on that
someone's actually watching to make sure
things are being done safely and Matthew
is just so much experience and you know
we really tell remarks on how like how
much of you know maybe with that well
it's definitely you but also the
character is being the captain in the in
the film he took the responsibility of
making sure that we were looked out for
and oh you tremendous thanks for that
because it really made our work better
you know it really did thank you so how
is the role like this offered to either
one of you do have to audition or do you
just get a call when I you know I have
to audition I don't know I don't think
Matthew asked to audition anymore
especially after you know all those
great new great films you've done but I
did another couple series of auditions
and my final audition was actually a
Skype session with the director johannes
and i just happened to be in yosemite at
the time of my mom and was a trip we've
been planning for four months so i
couldn't bail on it and they said okay
well scott you in from yosemite so I was
there with you know the mountains in the
background the forest around me just you
know reading these lines and doing this
kind of like scuba stuff and it was just
the funniest audition I've ever had and
I and it somehow clicked and worked and
then next thing you know I was in the
Dominican I remember you talking about
then yeah maybe cuz Republican I know
they sent they sent the script and I you
know I it's always flattering you know
for somebody to to think of you for
their film and send you the script and
and ask you to participate and the
reason I wanted to do this one just
because it my father was a drive-in
theater manager and these were the kind
of films that my dad really enjoyed
playing at the movie
because it was such an audience pleaser
you know that they loved this kind of
movie like a great summer movie that
that is filled with all of the elements
of a horror film but without the
supernatural aspects to it you know so I
wish my dad were alive to see it because
I know he'd really love this movie
grannie dude thank you okay thanks guys